i pursued boxing because i was such a
little shrimp and such a non-athlete
my brother roger and kenny were just you
know basketball players and football
players and
track stars and one day my brother roger
encouraged me to go to palmer park
recreation center to
participate in boxing i did that and
from 1970 to
where we are today boxing became a part
of my life
i've told people all over the world that
bruce lee was one of my idols
mainly because of his of his mental
stability
because of his fighting spirit because
it was more it was more mental than just
physical for him it was like what he
called emotional content
and for me that's when i succeeded
when i had to face major obstacles and
major opponents
like tommy hearns roberto duran marvin
hagler
because of my mental stability i was
able to beat those guys
without question bruce lee uh relates to
athletes of all kind
of every kind because it's all about
having everything in sync to perform
at the uh at the highest it all
ties in together i tell these boxers
today on the contender
that you must your mind your body your
spirit
must all connect to get the best
results bruce was an example of what
materialized from hard work
and there were no boundaries there was
no racial barriers there wasn't nothing
people saw bruce lee as a
a major force a positive force
and he was special
well that was the most amazing thing
about bruce was the fact that he could
generate so much speed and velocity
and his punches short punches
that he used his body and his and his
um the type of leverage he was able to
gain
because he knew he understood the
mechanics of the body
that was special what impressed me the
most about bruce was his
his smoothness i mean he was gliding he
was glide and it was not
he was not methodical he was very
spontaneous in his movement and
everything he did was for a reason he
just didn't move to just be
cute he moved for a reason to get in
line to get in position
to throw something to position himself
everything
was for a reason bruce lee
had charisma he had that he had a
package he could fight
he was versatile he was smart
he was deadly and he seemed
like he was the least guy uh
that could defend himself but he had
such an ability to outperform
anyone no matter what size
he could all no matter how strong bruce
lee always had a way
and he did it with style and that's what
i love that he did with style
well only bruce lee could really perform
and execute
the type of punches he threw the power
the speed
the accuracy that he threw his punches
um
you know i have not seen too many uh
other martial artists
in that league i love jackie chan
um i love uh
gently i mean those those guys
remind me a great deal of bruce lee
i don't think of anyone that reaches
that level bruce lee is an icon
he is you know in the dictionary
you say greatest he said bruce lee
that's
the way it is he was he stood he was
second to none he stood uh
he stayed out from the rest what makes
bruce stand out
is because of his charisma is because he
is so accurate so powerful and he's so
smart
and he had that he had that um that
mental stability
that very few people can reach and
maintain
to compete at the highest level